you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chess calm
and I just got paired up playing a 15-2
game all right let's see what to do
let's start with let's give the Sicilian
a try why not I was ready to play a c6
but let's maybe test the tactical waters
some so hmm
6r d6 let's go for d6 and the big moment
here opens the ceiling with the d4
Bishop to b5 and Bishop b5 I'm going to
play Knight to d7 avoid the light square
bishop exchange all right we don't have
that let's just take Queen takes Knight
takes let's see
okay so we're headed for a night Oh F
Knight f6 right now
nice III to defend okay so they're not
going to have some by Nover d5 with this
line and now the super flexible a6 move
let's see what this is a big moment here
for white any different options I may be
shooting soon for the e5 advance okay so
hmm
playing f3 in order to do what exactly
maintain a bishop on this square I
imagine rules out Knight to g4 and I
think the additional features that it
permits a g4 advance okay
I think as a start what I'm considering
now is a five and yeah I think I want to
go with E 5 e 5 and then keep a close
eye over the weekend square on d5 hmm
other moves to consider I guess I could
consider B 5 I don't really want to go
into a dragon setup not bad but it's not
really it's not really my thing
well really the society in general isn't
so much my thing but play and learn
experiment some let's let's give this a
go yeah so d5 is a big hole now but I do
gain something establish a pond in the
center and he has to now find this
strongly placed knight on d4 needs to
find a new home so he's not so well
placed on b3 but I do have this weakness
on d5 so Bishop to e6 probably yeah
let's get this in right now I need to
take some good care of the d5 square
given time I may want to play h5 I don't
know if Y will be so quick to play g4
but I may look to play h5 which kind of
puts a halt to this kingside pawn storm
that is quite common I believe this is
an English attack that white is aiming
for however with this move here it kind
of seems slightly misplaced the bishop
for one it's
it's on a half-open file for white so
you know there's no direct pressure on
the D file now and I can already
consider playing d5 myself the quite
liberating move that moved that you
really strive for in the Sicilian is
there some drawback connected with this
early d5 advance not so sure about that
hmm sometimes there's a worry of Knights
e5 but I have that covered what would be
the big drawback with playing d5 or
should I just say to myself you know
what
there's no rush were playing this I
could do it one move later and instead
make another developing move like Bishop
to e7 well he doesn't have very many
options does he I'm not going to go
about it with g6 Bishop g7 so I'm
leaning more towards committing my king
Bishop instead of my queen Knight I'm
not sure which of these two is better
for him so hmm well one thing I also
have to take into account is that if I
do not play d5 right now maybe white can
play g4 and then me to move like d5 with
a kick of my knight in I can maybe no
longer rely upon my nice position
however that said maybe if Bishop e7 g4
I could invest this one move preventing
g5 and then on my next turn play this
this would be a far more committal move
for white playing g4 then when compared
to this a CH six reply which does secure
my Knights position on f6 for enough
for me to get this advance in so I'm
going to shoot for this Bishop to e7 on
g4 I'll play h6 and then aim for this
you know when g4 is played some serious
weaknesses come about h3 h4 f4 is the
main one since I already have pawned
support for that square I'm already
controlling it for with upon and I get
pretty much already anticipate that
white will have to Castle queenside if
they're playing g4 it's just so
weakening to the Kings side so this
earlier thought ahead of d5 mmm
Knight c5 is now available in reply I
could play Knight here though Knight to
d7 that certainly doesn't seem so bad
hmm is it time to commit my knight let's
see anything wrong with that yeah let's
go with this
also on this is a super sensitive square
for white see for a knight repositioning
to this square is quite good connected
with this quite natural rook c8 move to
a half-open file Knight b6 into here hmm
okay well what's my first thought with
this move it's looking to clamp down in
this structure there might be some idea
with playing against the b6 square this
is a hole in my position but that said I
don't know that white is going to Castle
queenside after having played this move
should I prevent this advance by playing
b6 not even allowing this clamping down
type move b6 and on a5 there's b5
this does make this square a bit
sensitive I think I'd be fine if they do
in fact try to clamp down in this
structure yeah I think I shouldn't I
should be fine the night would be the
most invasive piece to arrive on this
square but I do have it covered a bishop
I feel like I can work around no issue
and if I need more support the other
night could come back here to watch over
b6 I think now's the time to castle or
not just yet let's get this rook here
rook c8 he knows his place I will
probably be castling soon maybe I have
an idea of h5 I don't I don't know let's
see if white commits his king I think
Queen e2 might be a pretty flexible move
but I'd be very surprised if white ends
up going Queen side okay well maybe I
should just get on with castle and then
d5 next mm-hmm
there may be a reason to play d5 prior
to castling though you know I think that
there is if castles castles d5 takes
takes takes Bishop takes my bishops
unprotected and allows Bishop takes pawn
with check and then Queen takes bishop
so I think playing d5 now it's different
because takes Knight takes yeah d5 takes
Knight takes Knight takes Bishop takes
he's unprotected and on any Bishop move
and any fancy Bishop move like I'd
always take this Knight you know Bishop
takes h7 is not happening with check in
this case I think playing d5 this is the
moment for that I'm not really giving
any consideration to taking this Knight
he's I'd identify this piece as the the
worst piece for why
right now so let's uh let's let's shoot
right for let's shoot right for d5 right
now yeah so I think I I imagine that
this is already equal equal maybe even
tending towards slightly better for
black I don't know will confirm it we'll
have a look with the computer afterwards
so not too many options got to recapture
this is you know the king can anticipate
the king being on g1 this is an open
diagonal it's a sensitive for the white
king I'll have I'd say some pretty good
King security a nice group of three
pawns all on their base squares okay so
I do need to be mindful of the
unprotected nature of my bishop some
bishop move
maybe Bishop here what would I do on
that yeah maybe I play Bishop c4 and say
where are you going okay well we don't
have that now I have to be careful of
Bishop takes here if I if I'm to counsel
hmm I'm thinking about just backing up
my bishop or moving forward Knight f6
however I Knight f6 Bishop f5 is a bit
annoying kicks my rook off of this file
I don't know that there's a great square
to pivot to along the C file I don't
think there's anything wrong with just
making one defensive move I kind of do
not want to allow this bishop to even
step foot in my position on f5 it's just
just feels like it's too disruptive so
I'm gonna make this one prep move on
Bishop d5 I think I have a quite
convenient reply in Queen c7
defense pressure against c2 and you know
this this move might run right into a
knight f6 move soon thereafter what I
think I can expect is a nice tempo
gained against the White Queen once
castled rook F to d8 is quite nice okay
things are certainly heating up we're
going to have a completely liquidated
pawn center I think it's important that
I get rid of this pawn allowing it to
advance and then having some concern of
ensuing advance and ensuing advance with
f6 I don't know how big a fan I am of
that I need to pick up the pace some
here clearly I think I can start though
with capture who its opening this
diagonal as well hmm maybe I'll be okay
with f5 I think I'd have something good
and reapply to that move hmm I kind of
want to welcome some exchanges here I
have a little bit of concern of some
pressure against my king
the bishop pointing down here like queen
h5 how do i define G 6 H 6 H 6 there
might be Bishop takes Bishop takes
Knight here pawn takes and then Bishop
c5 I don't know this bishops gonna be a
really strong piece I have two pawns
that are basically frozen on light
squares and that's not sure about that
hmm
castles Queen H v g6
castles f5 maybe the N bishop takes and
exchanged arcs where bishops and then I
could have a nice post for my knight on
f6 I'm gonna give this a go
mmm you know if there's already some
tricks castles pawn takes Knight takes
there's Bishop takes h7 Queen h5 hitting
my knight okay well maybe Queen c7
instead hmm let's go with Queen c7 I'm a
bit scared to Castle you know this
tactic is showing up in ensuing
positions is it not
as soon as f3 is on board this Queen now
has let's say in an indirect influence
along the fifth-ranked if I am castled
she does pivot here with tempo and in
hits these uh fifth-ranked squares so
that's a bit of a surprising move I'm
being perfectly honest the queen or
Knight
I may end up in a pin I don't think that
that's something that should bother me
so much I could consider Queen takes
pawn I mean what's wrong with that
Bishop here Queen g5 seems like a quite
you know a pretty reliable square no
well I got to pick up the pace let's
give this a shot a centralized Queen
with tempo hitting b2 hitting the Bishop
Bishop d4 to defend I think that this is
a fine home on g5 additionally if the
bishop is here well of course the knight
cannot make use of d4 and this is
something I need to be a bit concerned
of a knight hitting on d4 rattling my
bishops position um it's it's a bit of
an iffy position here for me I I do have
some concern because I'm still one move
away I know it's just one move away from
castling but one move in a completely
open position like this can be a big
problem one move you know I still need
to castle just being uncounseled and one
move away from castling in an open
position this could spell trouble for me
but
not really seeing a great way that white
could take advantage of this fact given
the time I will castle notice I don't
have to worry about Queen here I did
have some concern about Queen takes pawn
though huh okay maybe I could get this
move in Knight c5 I think that that's an
ideal defend here do you have the Queen
and the rook there I'm gonna go with
this mm-hmm Bishop here's an idea but
then I have problems all in this file
I'm gonna go with this move
don't think I'm blundering with that
it's a very active move he's he has now
a great restriction placed on him on e6
he has to defend f7 okay so let's see
alright I'm taking here with check are
they just going to move their King um I
don't think I'll have a problem with
that if they with her King I do have
queenie 7 to defend this pawn i don't
want to play rook here cuz he already
has one job well no I could do that
actually he is unprotected okay so I'm I
think I'm certainly going to take with
the Queen because it does hit with Chuck
and I need to still address this point
I'd like to see an ending although I
don't know if I could really say I'm
better this Bishop is still it's in a
spot where it could target these guys so
rook c7 should be holding everything
right here just exposes me to checks on
the e-file let's do this now to pick up
the pace I'm still one move away from
castling
okay so squares I have h5 covered queen
efore might be a potential double attack
somehow once castled Queenie four hits
here which she hit somewhere else not
really okay I think I can now just
castle safely um however maybe no I
should get castle I should really get
castled
oh yeah yeah let's get counseled there's
not going to be any tricks on h7 no
tricks no this is already the the flight
square I'm looking into it does weaken
f6 and h6 but there are no knights my
phone does not have any Knights my
opponent does not have a bishop that
could really be a great inconvenience to
me should it arrive on f6 a queen maybe
but I could always challenge it I'd have
the potential to challenge if he's on f6
but short story I'm looking at g6 as my
flight square additionally I'm seeing
ideas of maybe undermining the bishop on
d3 with this b3 move I could take and
maybe grab this guy at some point
additionally the bishop on d3 does have
a certain restriction placed on him he
has to defend c2 okay there might be
ideas of rook takes Bishop here if I'm
not careful the Queen has to defend this
rook so I feel like this rook needs to
go elsewhere however alright so if I
take this pawn rook takes Bishop C I see
now okay
maybe maybe Bishop 2d hmm bishop here I
want to trade one rook
I want to reroute my bishop I also want
to get this rook out of the line of fire
so rook takes Bishop isn't played this
should be a fine move right I still want
to get in g6 soon let's do this
I don't think I'm falling for any
tactics I really do want to get this and
I'm still feeling like I'm one move
behind before I'm safe King why is
earlier I was saying it about I want to
get counseled one move away well I still
want this move in so I don't have to
worry anymore about Bishop takes h7 I'm
getting out of the line of fire flip
takes bishop maybe mm maybe at some
point this is back on as a threat
you know maybe let's see okay so what's
the queen up to I can take care but I
don't really know about that I feel like
this is the correct well maybe this move
hits should I take this pawn now I'm
gambling some rook here is very active I
feel like I need to do this right now
let's get this move in yeah let's get
that move in rook here could still
happen maybe maybe I play this though
my queen could Doug be kicked away she
has a restriction placed on her the
Queen has pressure on the rook there
might be tactics here and I should also
be aware of the possibilities I have
Bishop takes g2 luring the King away
freeing the Queen along the fifth-ranked
in this direction towards the Kings side
playing a little time here to kick it up
play faster so let's see flight square
h3 this would be an unprotected pond
because the
is this pin so they still have back rank
issues they need to they need to do this
at some point and maybe my queen could
at some stage pose a threat against h3
and some something else like if she was
here and the bishop move the pawn is on
h3 I could take here this should be a
pretty strong piece what I'd like to
have happen is trade one rook just on
because my rook here I feel like he's a
bit out of play and tying down my pieces
I don't like having this situation here
with my queen defending my rook it's not
a it's not a fun job they might be
considering this move and then this or
something maybe because yeah I'm still
you know if this if this move actually
you know what
mmm on c4 I can't drop back actually on
c4 I was thinking Bishop c6 in on Queen
takes rook Bishop takes pawn however
after c4 bishop c6 b5 kicks my queen
away from this indirect defense of my
rook so on c4 I don't believe I can play
Bishop to c6 as clever as it may look
like it's the better of me after b5 be
far excuse me okay so where would I go
on c4 Bishop back here okay see for sure
enough is hitting I do have defense of
my rook I gotta play here
b4 might hit and I'd have to go back
here I know they're being sneaky there
this is very natural move but yeah
before I think wins
so b4 could still be played yeah and it
is so I don't have very many options so
at least that's nice you know why he I
won't get caught up in spending too much
time so they're gonna have a nice clamp
down in my structure here if they play
c5 right
well today you don't have a flight
square they still have to get this move
in and I think I'm wanting to play this
really soon I should do it now
hmm I'm gonna play this move no they
can't up hitting their Bishop okay
Bishop here I could play rook here nice
pin pressure on b4 this is unprotected
I'm ready to double up the things are
things are certainly heating up here
quite an open position they they really
should have this move in soon but you
know what I'm already generating some
threat which is not allowing this King
security hmm probably just double hmm
yes I need to get doubled and we're
gonna have a completely liquidated is
this position going to be stripped of
all rooks I will not do well if it is a
bishop ending alone
this guy is a forever target not cool I
want to keep the Queen's on given time
oh I did not even consider that mm-hmm
well let's play actively yeah let's play
here hit the Queen hitting this pawn I
may end up with in a slightly ugly ugly
structure my F pawn you know I can turn
into an e pawn and isolated e pawn I
could be playing with soon so hmm
rook takes b4 next or rook here
okay Queen there huh all right I think I
have to go for this grab this pawn these
guys are split okay they still have to
sort out their back rank I'd be happy to
have the Queen's come off actually could
play quicker for one yeah and yeah let's
see I'm on this Bishop rook takes Bishop
Bishop takes Queen takes or pawn takes
oh my goodness I think I'm busted I'm
busted that was a really nice shot I did
not even see that
ouch hmm
rook takes f7 was really nice and why
actually did I take with my queen I
could have taken with my king I know I'm
running right into this uh I'm busted
this is a losing position oh and why did
I not take with my King King takes here
I mean I saw that the bishop move was
going to happen oh I don't know why did
that hmm yeah I took with the bishop or
the Queen and this is a losing move but
oh yeah that one won't completely
shocked me rook takes f7 I don't know
that this is really working now rook
takes f7 suppose I just take with the
king hmm what is white having in store
in this position oh you know what it
might still be winning huh with rook
here let me just before I um I just
refreshed that yeah that that turned out
to just be a winning shot even if I took
with the king let me just flip the board
yeah if I took with the King there's
rook check and now wow I mean here just
to highlight
this is brutal I have to give up my
queen rook takes f7 wow that was a
really nice shot huh yeah I took with
the Queen no it's it's losing regardless
of anything it's just this idea I did
not even consider rook takes f7 that's a
really nice shot yeah I think this is
working
regardless of how I recapture here I
don't see a way I could take advantage
of their back rank hmm I thought I was
just like a move or two away from being
quite quite all right but you know this
seems to be working
rook takes f7 and Wow what do I do about
that
wow I might already be lost after this
move Queen here you know cuz the Queen
has the pin on my bishop she has
pressure against the rook and Wow huh
let me just double-check here I'll check
it out with the computer but hmm 6 f7
it's clearly losing and even if I took
with the king there's check I know I
showed this move but suppose I go here I
think I'm still busted after this and
now the threat is Queen h8 and it's all
my stuff that Wow
I don't see how I stopped Queen h8 this
is just a really nice tactical shot
right there I did not even consider it
hmm I guess I think I should have
expected some some tactic with so many
pieces on these F and E files and the
coordinated effort they have on e6
a good shot okay well I thought it was a
pretty even game
um maybe be again before I look at it
with the computer maybe I actually
should not have played g6 like this and
hmm could I have actually gotten away
with the Queen takes pawn I'm not quite
sure about that because of this great
activity this is a super piece mind you
he's a really strong Bishop and my rook
is out of play it's just conveniently
defending he's an excellent defender an
excellent aggressive piece and I have
loose pieces here White is the much
better uh much more coordinated side
let's say and look at the active when
you could do a rook comparison you know
he's a he's a he's a dead a dud an FA
and so too is he's tactically vulnerable
loose pieces I'm in a pin I don't know I
don't know that I could grab on the 85
hmm okay well I'm definitely gonna learn
something from this looking at it with
the computer so let me give me him
give me a minute and I'll go ahead and
pull it up okay let's see what we could
take away from this one I do feel like I
did obtain an even position when I got
the d5 break-in so let's see so far
pretty even does it really like Bishop
d3 Bishop e3 is much more common you
know because he doesn't have very many
squares you know you don't want to go
here here is not really a bother I mean
for one I don't have to worry about the
pawn kicking my knight it's a it's a pin
that's easily broken with Bishop to e7
this is probably the much more flexible
move to go with maybe even though there
might be a reason to even delay the the
Bishop move I was saying earlier that
this might be an idea to drop the knight
in to c4 and for wonder if that does
happen if the bishop
and play from f1 to see fork if he can
take the night out by playing just one
move light is essentially saving saving
a tempo that's just one reason why it's
it's going a bit deeper but it's a
reason to not declare the bishops
intention so quickly when compared to
the Bishop III move
okay so anyhow Bishop d3 is on board
Bishop e7 any great changes really
pretty even pretty standard moves on the
black end right I Norv quite common just
some things to question is the move
order but I don't think there's a too
great a difference
it goes for d5 now and let me make sure
I am correct on this if castles castles
d5 is no longer good because of this
variation I was citing sure enough there
is that tactic so it's important to
actually hit with d5 at this moment all
right
takes takes takes takes mm okay an ever
so slight pull for black I think it just
popped up for a moment Bishop f5 excuse
me okay they Castle alright it likes
Bishop e6 I played there should be six
help me out help me out stock fish where
could I have improved f4 it likes to
castle now that's a bit surprising
I went with Queens Queen c7 and that's a
big of a deal but I thought on castle
there's takes takes and then Bishop here
takes oh I didn't look deep enough
because at the end I'm getting C - it's
not pointing out C - right now but I
could take on C - to restore the
material it likes even better Bishop d6
hmm okay how could I have better
I should have calculated clearly a bit
deeper in that variation hmm
you know okay so when I miss a tactic
like this or an idea or I'm not seeing
deep enough when I'm really kind of
questioning is you know how could I have
seen it maybe a little bit different
this this variation is trying to I was
visualizing this takes takes and I think
I only went as far as oh here and then
Queen here and takes the knight I didn't
even look how things are different or
the the type of pieces that were
exchanged this still this is still an
open position even if somehow I'm not
able to regain the pond I have two
bishops in an open position and maybe I
should at least consider that I should
give some value to that okay all right
yeah I'm just he's like the little
mental notes that I make to myself to
try and you know and improve in future
games
that's a bishop that they're giving up
in this variation here sure they have
the tactic of taking on h7 and then
going here and then taking the night but
that was a bishop for a knight exchange
sure they grabbed the pawn but I have a
really strong well I have the bishop
pair and I could go in for roof takes
here if I want to what's let me
just being a bit curious here what's the
follow-up Queen D Fornell rook takes C -
okay well my question is suppose Queen
here Wow look at the evaluation and this
is being down upon it likes black
clothes - upon and a half rook to e8 now
whose pieces are playing hmm Wow yeah in
as mentioned during the game the Bishop
on d3 what an enormous piece he was kind
of a really securing White's Queen side
mmm
he's not around anymore we have a loose
piece on e3 problems here
you know White has to clear their pieces
off with the e-file one would think
mm-hmm
okay that's interesting castles right
away it's fine here's another thing
suppose f5 is structural shift okay it
likes this move and then my ID was this
and that's fine my idea with that is to
to exchange dark square bishop so that
way I can rely upon a really strong post
for my knight on f6 now this would be
nice I also with this kind of a
variation I wanted to I would want to be
assured I could eliminate white's bishop
air Bishop c5 okay so those are
certainly the two things to consider you
know with Castle you have to look into
takes the combination with takes and
then takes on h7 queen h5 and also the
structural shift the the push the f5
advance okay I want Queen c7 it's fine
likes councils right away instead of
Queen takes mm-hmm okay
just not grabbing right away here Bishop
f4 mm a little bit uncomfortable
especially with that move huh oh yeah
that's tough I do not like this move at
all f-five Wow how many loose pieces do
you want on the a file that's a tough
move Queen to Bishop d6 94 this isn't if
this is this is not fun to play as black
I mean yeah computers not gonna sweat it
out but uh all these loose pieces and
you're reacting to your opponent's
threats like this okay well I just
grabbed the you pawn right away bishop
d4 Queen g5 tight game castles castles
huh I'm too concerned about this why
should I be you know it's indirectly
defended isn't it Queen takes B bishop
d5 and why could resign okay I went one
night c5 which is still fine takes takes
takes check you know that's an even game
Rock c7 and where was the final mistake
here rook F to c8 huh mmm I didn't give
too much weight to this because I wanted
to keep some defensive f7 however hmm
what did I play there you know I'm
trying to get out of the way of this
tact if I if I'm taking here there's
rook takes c6 takes and then I made it
okay rook after c8 Bishop d5 clean f4
let's go back back to Bishop e6 I played
g6 slight pull for white a thing winning
here
c4 I have to play Bishop e6 here be four
hits in his winning Queen takes here on
the other hand I'm winning okay
I ship back before Queenie 7 c5 rook da
rocha d5 hmm missed this was too natural
to just do the doubling I didn't
consider Bishop here hmm still even
Bishop b3 rook d4 still even Queen d7
hmm
this was too tempting was it not to take
on b4 how many of you would have just
taken on b4 and fell for that same
tactic as me you know it's just a
winning shout what can you do hmm I need
to be accurate here Queen to d7 Bishop
takes Queen takes Queen takes F takes
rook takes c6 rook takes b4 only now and
then finally White has to make a flight
square and then I could do the the
typical secure your king position first
or it's even liking rook to be 5 however
I'd probably want to secure my king my
king position doing something like this
it does call for c6 and I guess at the
end I'm dropping this guy ok this is a
bit uncomfortable okay I have this smell
a nun takes takes and that that'll be a
draw it does however point out I thought
it popped up this King g7 you know this
should be a draw well it's a nice
tactical shot didn't didn't see it
coming
but a pretty even game right up to that
point hmm okay yeah I definitely learned
some you know aside from just this
tactical shot on route takes f7
certainly learned learned a thing with
the seeing really trying to see a little
bit deeper with that combination of the
capture on
this square here at this moment
counselling is in fact quite alright
recognizing the pieces that are in fact
being exchanged not seeing it as only oh
okay I'm gonna be down upon but to
realize that I'm gonna have the bishop
pair it is an open position this is a
really good piece that they're giving up
and my rook is actually then coming to
life so that pawn that I'm losing kind
of from that series of exchanges you
know should this should this come about
these this series of exchanges is adding
some value I know I'm down upon but it
also now adds some value to my rook on
c8 you know he's not out of play you
know with the bishop on d6 one might say
well he's not really doing so much
without the light-square bishop this is
back on there is no pressure it's a very
active peace in the bishop pair okay
interesting game as usual feel free to
leave any feedback to this video and as
usual I hope you got something out of it
that's all for now
take care